I would I spent last summer in Turkey I
was there to do to do research on
refugees and to do demographic research
because very little is known about you
know how many people are how old and
with women and men and children I mean
see UNHCR has has these broad numbers
that you come up here but but there's
very little done on who who the refugees
are so that's what we were we were doing
and as we went out to interview people
we realized how much they were suffering
and we always brought some diapers to
the mothers and baby clothes and things
that they needed and throughout the
winter we brought well my colleagues
brought brought coal and wood for them
so that so that we became kind of a
research a distributed I would say we're
not we weren't incorporated what
interested me most of what what upsets
me a lot is that is that as Natasha was
talking about we have this UN Convention
on refugees which only covers a
particular group and not those fleeing
certain types of violence climate
climate there are you know so many
climate refugees fleeing disasters but
countries who sign the Refugee
Convention are obligated to accept a
refugee on their soil and the rep the
person will say I'm a refugee and they
are and they are obligated to allow that
person to apply for asylum however it's
a catch-22 because they do everything
they can to keep the refugees out so you
can you are legal if you're in and
you're actually legal if they're out but
since you're kept out you have to go to
Europe let's say Europe or even the
United States
we know that in an irregular way and so
many people are risking their lives to
get the get the the right the human
rights that they that they are entitled
to and so 4000 people died on the
Mediterranean Sea last year and the
European Union has I I asked them why
don't refugees fly
I mean they could fly they they pay
smugglers 1 to $2,000 dollars a head
like you could fly from Istanbul to
Berlin for 300 dollars they don't fly
because you have to have documents to
fly you have to have a visa to fly if
you're a refugee you're you're sometimes
there without documents and certainly
you don't have a visa because refugees
don't get visas so the trick is to get
in and then you're legal and so people
have to people have to take these very
dangerous dangerous journeys first they
escape danger and life-threatening
circumstances in the countries they left
then they had to maybe leave the camps
and the camps are very much underfunded
I don't know if anyone's going to talk
about that 50 cents a day for for food
in the camps for each refugee they so
they say the camps and staying there 19
years is not really you know the
prospects of the future are not good and
so refugees want to go to places where
they can work places where they can have
a livelihood where they can live where
they can educate their children and so
they they have to risk their lives yet
again on this incredibly dangerous
journey because because the European
Union will not let you fly and enter
Europe and the United States it's the
same without a proper visa even though
you're legally entitled to this and so
now Europe is sending now the
NATO then North Atlantic Treaty
Organization is sending warships into
the Mediterranean Sea and they and the
pretense is we are going to pick up
human traffickers and we are not going
to send refugees back because they're
not really allowed by international law
to do that but there are no smugglers on
the boat that bring refugees from
Circuit agrees
you